at just four years old jameel had
already experienced war
his 16 year old cousin had lived through
four of them they didn't survive a visit
to their grandfather's grave
five children were killed in the
cemetery in jabalia refugee camp on
sunday all but one of them from the same
family
this cemetery the israelis hit is like a
park for our children in our religion we
consider it as our final resting place
there's no security for our children i
ask the international community to
pressure israel to stop killing our
children
this witness says he saw the explosion
as the boys sat around the gravesite
just a few seconds after they passed me
i heard the sound of an armed drone hit
the children
it was quiet there was nothing going on
in the cemetery it was safe i looked up
and found the children dead
the previous day four children in the
camp were killed
some as they went to buy treats from a
market
barely an adult and an only child khalil
abu hamada was hoping to marry soon and
give his parents grandchildren
we could all be martyrs almost every
year we have war and massacres when
khalil was born i had a feeling he
wouldn't live long but i never expected
he would die this way
witnesses say the damage to these cars
and the force of the explosion are
consistent with israeli airstrikes over
the years the israeli military says 200
of the rockets fired by palestinian
islamic jihad misfired and some
civilians were killed
it says the incident at jamalia cemetery
is still being investigated but the
first incident which killed four
children was the result of an errant
rocket fired by the armed group
no one here believes that messiah
it's not true i saw with my own eyes the
israeli rocket from the roof of my home
the israelis massacred my son there is
no doubt the palestinian groups are not
responsible
the jabalea refugee camp lost nine boys
in this latest round of violence with
israel during their short lives they
experienced the terror and loss of war
after war with no chance of a peaceful
childhood
natasha ghanim al jazeera gaza